hello everyone and welcome to game 10
from the 1960 World Chess Championship
match between Michael Tao and Mikhail
Botvinnik now you probably remember from
my video about game 8 talent Alexander
Koblenz had this brilliant idea that Tao
should go all-out try and win more win
one more game as if he had a four point
lead in the match then that that lead
would be practically impossible for
botanique to overcome but tall was game
number 8 and then in game number 9 he
ran straight into botanique home
preparation against that sacrifice tile
had a head-on e6 so that was a pretty
brilliant game by both Munich and now
instead of being three points in the
lead now tile is still one point in the
lead but as tal says that he doesn't
feel like he's in the lead he starts
that this is like a whole new match as
now he faces a new improved confident
bought tunic that won the previous two
games and now again botanique has the
white pieces and towel really has to
figure out what to do here
so botany plays d4 and tells us that he
didn't really know what to prepare for
this game but he did have an idea that
for some reason he thought that that
Botvinnik would definitely go for the
semi variation against the King's Indian
as in more in some of the games
botanique play Knight to f3 and the
second move kind of showing that he's
not really interested in the semi
variation and it's exactly this move
order that kind of gift
gave tall the inside that botany will
indeed go for the for the cemetry
variation so Knight to f6 c4 g6 the
Kings Indian defense Knight to c3 Bishop
to g7
now e4 d6 this is the classic line and
here botanique plays f3 so he does go
for the semi variation we have castles
Bishop to e3 now II five d5 and c6
Queen to d2 c captures on d5 and seek
after sandy 5 here tall kind of just
mentioned that for for a short time in
the book that Knight captures on d5
isn't really good for white because
white can never win this d6 pawn
our point being that after Knight to c6
and castles you'll never get to win the
d6 pawn because of simply a knight to d4
and hour after Bishop captures Bishop to
e6 Queen moves and now he captures ECAP
force on d4 and the black is much better
in this position
so after seek after Sundy 5c captures on
b5 and now a six a useful move preparing
b5 in the future and not allowing any of
White's pieces to occupy occupy the b v
square and here botanique plays g4 we
have 9 B to d7 and here Knight G to E -
this is the position tall as tall did
prepare the Kings Indian defense against
the same each variation for this match
and for this game in particular tall
picked a couple of games and
specifically a one game he played
against the glycogen Porter's in 1958 in
the inter zonal tournament because tall
had this position as white and the
Glitter said that this position is black
so in that game h4 h4 was played by tall
and gligar rich followed with h5 and it
was a it was a it was a decent game
black they didn't really have any
problems
so after this Knight B to d7 botanique
first plays Knight to e2 he prepares
Knight 2 G 3
so if h5 will be played in the future
then G captors and h5 will be an idea as
the knight will also support to the h5
square
so tell immediately goes for h5 and here
this there was this position on the
border plenty of times in the past and
here white usually had three main ideas
it was G captors on H five pushing the
pawn to g5 or defending with h3 but in
this game but when he goes for the
never-before-seen or so tal thought as
he's never seen this move before Bishop
to g5 and he doesn't know was this
Bishop to g5 an idea he just found over
the border was it it was it a really
home preparation but later a later he
will kind of think that it was it was a
in over the board decision but you can
never really tell what Botvinnik because
sometimes the bottom Anik will think for
10 minutes about the move that he
already prepared at home
so here top laid H captors on g4f
capture Sun g4 and here night the c5 by
tau now immediately piling up on that
efore pawn Queen to a5 will be an idea
in the future and here for his next move
a Botvinnik thought for 25 minutes and
in the end he decided to play Knights to
g3 he decided to sacrifice the pawn on
g4 but there were a lot of things to
consider
I mean you can't really protect the g4
pawn with something like h3 because you
lose thee for point Knight captors
Knight captures and now simply knife
captures you attack the Queen on d2
bishop capture 78 Knight captor Sundy -
now Bishop to c7 attacking the d6 pawn
and now Knight to f3 check King attacks
night and now e4 in defending the knight
and also opening up the attack to the be
to pawn button captures and now rook
attacks Bishop Bishop moves and now
Bishop captures and b2 and black black
black gains a very you know a decent
position of being a pawn up and white
didn't achieve anything here so after
this night the c5 move
botany sets to sacrifice the G pawn but
by playing Knight to g3 and defending
the e4 pawn so Bishop captures on g4
tall accepts it and now B for attacking
the knight Knight moves to d7
we have h3 now Bishop to f3 attacking
the rook and now rook to h2 and now the
rook will be a lot more active on a
student it was on h1 and here the bishop
on f3 isn't really doing all that much
even though black is up upon so here a 5
and tall says this a5 was a completely
it wasn't really in the spirit of the
position at all thought that it creates
it creates some opportunities on the
Queen side but actually later he
suggests that a Queen to b6 would be
would definitely have been a better move
going for that b4 pawn also preparing
Queen to d4 so this would have been
better that estas suggests but in the
game a5 was played and here both winning
played b5 top layer atop lay in this
sharp a5
what's the idea that if botanique plays
Queen to e3 attacking tells Bishop on f3
then talk would go for a nice piece
sacrifice with a capture some v4 tonight
the b5 and now Knight capture some d5
attacking the Queen pawn captures and
now Bishop to f6 now if you capture an
f3 you lose the bush when g5 so after
Queen captures on f3 and Bishop captures
on g5 Knight captures on d6 now no White
is practically lost this was the
position that tal says then it's a
double-edged position where black really
gets a lot for a piece as f5 is coming
and the point being that you can't
capture this night because of rook to a3
and it's a very sharp short position
Queen has to move also Queen has to
protect the night on g3 so after the
Queen moves now Knight checks King moves
now knife to f6 attacking the knight and
d6 Knight moves Queen captures and if I
would check Knight moves and now other
rogue comes into the game and now all of
black's pieces are eyeing the king and
the night there it's white is completely
lost here so a lot of you know a lot of
ideas to this a5 move by tall but botany
completely ignores it and he simply
pushes be 5 so Queen to b6 by tau and
here Queen - Queen to f2 and this is a
where tal really thought that even
though he's up a pawn but when he really
really knows what he's doing as if the
Queen's come off the board then the game
will practically be transferred to the
Queen side and toss pieces are kind of
stuck on the King side so this could
favourable Tunica lot so here tell
exchanges immediately on f2 may be a
better decision would would have been
better to h5 and then allowing both
eunuchs to capture the Queen and b6 are
following Knight captures from b6 but
okay tell the thought doesn't mention
this idea so Queen captures rook
captures and now Bishop to h5
we have b6 now and b6 was an over the
board decision it's hard to say was it
the strongest move but it was definitely
the strongest practical move as it
really creates a weakness here this a5
phone is now a weakness the b7 point is
now a weakness and the b6 boner really
really makes things a lot harder of
course you can't capture it because then
you lose the knight on f6 here rook F to
c8 was played
we have night to b5 attacking the d6
pawn and now Knight to e8 simply
defending the pawn and here Knight
captures on h5 and Thal says that this
was this wasn't the best move because
okay you do want to capture it but this
night and g3 actually had a very nice
purpose it was protecting the e4 pawn
better was hard to say if it was better
but if he were rook to e3 to defend the
b6 pawn then black has this very
annoying Bishop to f6 move and after you
capture now on h5 now black has bishop
to h4 pinning that rook and you don't
really have a square to retreat to do
with your knight
so after we play a move Bishop captures
Bishop captures pawn captures and now
you're just down the exchange and black
is winning this game so after this night
to e8 move botanique did play Knight
captures on h5 but tau recommends the
very sneaky rook to be one that this was
better for botany candidate gave white
better chances the idea is now if you
capture Knight captures now you get
Knight captures on d6 knife captors and
rook captures and this position is fine
for white his pieces will become active
the other rook is coming into the game
also so it may be an improvement but
okay after night we ate botanique did
play Knight captures on h5 we have G
captors on h5 and Bishop to e3 now now
defending the b6 pawn not all has night
the c5 and now you see that the pawn on
e4 is attacked and botanique has to has
to exchange bishop for a night here so
Bishop captures pawn rook captures and
now Bishop to d3 rook a to c8 now
thought that was up on the C file we
have King to e2
to see one training rooks Rock captures
rook captures and rook to f1 offering a
trader of the other look as well at all
of course the clients this rook to c5
as he doesn't wanna trade even the rook
as toss pieces are kind of stuck on the
King side for now at least
so rook to be one Bishop to f6 and now
Knight to 83 this Bishop to f6 was
actually a powerful defensive move I
thought that was that was stopping the
knight to a7 idea because if 92 87 then
tall has Bishop to d8 and after this
night sacrifices itself for the pawn
pawn can actually capture it because now
after b7 now doll has Bishop to c7
stopping it and after botany brings out
the Queen but should capture screen
captures King to f8 defending the knight
now D captures on c6 and now King 2 is 7
you can't grab the pawn because Bishop
to b5 simply wins
so King to e7 and now after rook checks
came to have sex Bishop to b5 night to
c7 attacking the bishop now you either
capture night and then rook captures
Bishop is very nice for black or you
move and then 96 and the black has a
very nice position here
so after this Bishop to have six
botanique so that this idea doesn't work
he played night 283
we have Bishop to d8 attacking the pawn
again and now Knight to c4 and the
Knight to c4 is a great idea by botany
what eunuch wants to get the knight this
to f5 but he could have done this
also by playing from a3 a nice to see to
to e3 to f5 and the plane get the c4 is
a small tactical error Wichita
immediately takes advantage of he pushes
f5 and now there's a problem you can
play each captures on f5 because of F or
you have to move the bishop you lose the
night or you capture the pawn you lose
the night this way so after a five-night
to e3 you can't really capture it and
now tell that instead of pushing to a4
but he didn't enjoy this
he decided F captures only for Bishop
captures on e4 and now King to h8
the thought says that this King to h8
move making a move like this is deadly
when your opponent is really a long time
and the botanique was really a long time
in this game before
this is move 34 and before the 40th move
was made he had like a couple of seconds
on his clock before reaching time
control King to D 3 by Buitoni tonight's
to have six now attacking the bishop
bishop to g2 we have King back to g8 and
now comes a for Bishop to e7 Bishop to
f3 Bishop to f8 rook to g1 check King to
h7 and now Bishop to e4 this is both
unique and making his 40th move and it
wasn't the greatest of moves but it's
like as tall says he his flag almost
fell here so tall had to play Knight
captures only four you have King
captures and here bishop to h6 now here
Tao could have sealed a move as the game
had to be adjourned and tal was
considering Tony that rook the c3 was
the strongest move in this position and
that it gave black the most chances to
actually win this game but he thought if
he seals this move then opportunity will
have an entire night to find all the all
the moves for each side so it will
probably be refuted so instead top
played to h6 and now he basically forced
both eunuch to seal a move so tau is the
one that will have the entire night
analyzing the other possible or
continuations so here the game was
adjourned botanics still the move and
later the next day they found that
botanique played Knight to f5 which was
pretty much forced you can't allow
Bishop captures so here rook to c4 check
was played King to d3 now rook captures
an a4 Knight captures on d6 and now Rock
the d4 check King moves
topless rookie actress on d5 and here we
have Knight to e4 Knight to e4 is a
devious idea by botany
now if you play rook to b5 to go for the
point simply Knight f6 and your
checkmated followed by ruby GA checkmate
so after Knight to e4 came to h8 not
allowing this but when he goes for a
knight to f6 now rook to d2 check he
moves and now rook to d8 preventing of
course checkmate on GA rook to g6
attacking the bishop and here tal did
consider a lot of moves
probably he says the Bishop to g7 was
was the best idea but he decided to play
a four as he again he had a devious trap
for Botvinnik rook captures on h6 a now
King to g7 attacking both night and rook
and now rook to h7 check and this was
one of the traps tal said for Botvinnik
now if both eunuch becomes greedy and
plays rook captures on h5 first then
after night King captures on f6 and rock
to h7 Toth has rook to b8 and tal wins
the game it seems like a really stupid
stupid place for the rook but actually
this wins the game
now there's no way for you to actually
prevent da for da for pawn from Queenie
if you go root K for simply rook to e8
again one goes forward and if you go
rook to h6 the try and get rook into the
game this way then
rook moves rope comes to d6 King to f5
but now the e pawn is also dangerous
King to e3 now comes a three hour rock
to d2 blocking get rook to e8 and after
rook blocks
rook to a4 and a completely winning game
for black but okay after this King to g7
move botanique doesn't go all greedy he
goes rook to h7 check King captures on
f6 and now rock out for some b7 it's a
lot more important at all still is up a
pawn but you know at least now botanique
can maybe hold this rope to d3 check
came to g2 defending the pawn and now
rook to b3 rook to a7 now comes a three
we have b7 into a5 rook to a3 capturing
the rook
now if of course you can capture the
rook because then the b-pawn Queen's
rook capture some b7 and now rook to a4
we have rook rook to be to check and
here after this rook to a for telling
you that he was never gonna win this
game because you can't push efore to
gain any any more space and now simply
rook to a5 check and you have to give up
the h5 pawn came to a 4 now you grab the
pawn if you don't grab it if you defend
it or something then rope to e5 again
there's just really no way to gain any
advantage from your pawn up so after
work today for rook to be 2 was played
with check we have King to f3 Rock to b3
check King back to g2 rook to e3 and
here Botvinnik played rook to h4 and in
this position tal actually offered the
draw and a draw was agreed upon as there
is no way to make progress here it's a
theoretical draw if you play something
like in g5 at going for the rock again
rook to a4 and you can never push efore
because that's where okay 5 check you're
never gonna get anything out of this
position so yeah after rook to h4 they
agree to a draw and so it'll definitely
stop the bleeding after losing two games
gay a game 10 is a draw and we we
officially as this
I don't okay I'm not gonna tell you how
many games this match has maybe some of
you don't know or some of you are maybe
lazy to check it out but we are
somewhere around the half of this match
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it thank you all for watching as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here and yeah I'll try to as I'm pretty
busy with the candidates and everything
but I will try to you know whenever I
can to release one game from this match
so this is game ten thank you for
watching and I will see you soon